thank you
[Music]
that being said welcome everybody to
another amazing episode of the careful
boys what we have in the hot seat today
Adelia hey Daddy deals
all right so you are in the hot seat
what we're just basically going to ask
you a bunch of questions and honestly we
probably don't get as steamy as we
should on this and it get and it starts
really cold but then we turn up the
temperature cool yeah but we got to work
really hard to turn up the temperature
today yeah she's gonna be difficult yeah
we've been hot seeding her the whole day
you're so open it's gonna be hard all
right it's hard to make me embarrassed
and we've asked so many questions
already but to kick it off let's get the
coldest question of it all from Bard
okay
if you had to describe asparagus to a
blind person
how would you do that uh I I love
asparagus I would say uh all right do
you smell my pee right now this is not
asparagus does
straight from the piss he'll remember
that I thought it was a vegetable
holy [__] it's a smelly follow-up
question to that I asked this and
actually went pretty viral if you were
to eat asparagus and then you squirted
how would that smell and would it affect
your squirt smell what did people say I
don't it's it's it needs to be tried but
it's working so square has elements of
pee but it isn't pee
so it's just other liquid yeah but like
would your squirt smell from the
asparagus you would have to be on like
very just asparagus only diet though for
it to like truly have an effect dude I
can eat like one piece of asparagus and
I'm like Oh my pee smell yeah yeah no
you can smell it yeah
so um you do that case study on your
podcast I feel like a lot of people yeah
I drink a lot of water so I can't smell
my own asparagus pee yeah I drink a lot
of water I drink like a gallon a day and
I still oh I don't even like asparagus
that much I love veggies hate fruit love
veggies
I like veggies but not as birds so you
uh just to get past the [__]
asparagus
let's go back
sour come on so you were you were
mentioning a question that you asked on
your podcast about like a woman's body
count yes but
if it was just men that made you
actually come what would your body count
be four I think four four wow that's why
celibacy easy I'm like I'm not missing
out on anything
is it because you're hard to make come
um yeah
I've Had A vibe
of Vibes are like oh that thing scares
me like I know how to tell you how to
make me calm like this guy who I was
obsessed with he was broke as [__]
[Laughter]
I was like oh my God so wait did he make
you come because it's still hitachi's I
count that as him making come really
yeah but like he's just Arthur with an
Excalibur that's even easier and yeah
listen that's the key yeah like listen
to her yeah in general but like body
count wise how many
she just wants to know
it's
I'm trying to think because I don't want
to say the exact number because I like I
lost count two girls girls and guys are
just guys
what what yeah what is yeah I have
separate categories because girls I've
hooked up with a lot of girls like oh
I've been in like 40 year old orgies
um so that's 40 at one step well I don't
I mean I didn't eat everyone's vagina
but I was like yeah is that like is your
Camp I did like a train with someone
like I don't know it was it was hard
like here's the thing I've only had
medium plus eating reviews from that org
because I was so overwhelmed like how do
I make her come if I'm like supposed to
have a tit in my hand and a butt in this
hand
um there's a lot of people
and there was no guys no it sounds like
a sorority to me sounds sexist to me
yeah yeah yeah
I'm celibate what can I say is there one
that you perform more if you're gonna do
like group sex would you prefer more
women or guys like I only do like groups
orgies with all women because like I
just think men ruin the vibe I think so
too I would agree you've got a thirsty
ass [__] like man why is this
too excited there
or it's like a harem situation and he
gets all the attention oh but I just
will say my number for men
less than half of a hundred I just it's
somewhere don't make us do math
no no it's better that way less than
half of 100 way more gangsters yeah it's
definitely less than 50 men what the
exact number is I don't know but it's
definitely less than 50. I never hit it
for I think the Modern Woman yeah I
think that's especially if you're like
especially for the amount of one night
stands I used to do yeah
so going back to
um asparagus
station uh for like so you and your pops
don't have a good relationship no [__]
him so he he's been very disapproving
for the for a long time can you remember
the last time where he was approving of
whatever you were doing when I was
interning for his company and he thought
I was gonna take over his job but then
he fired me because really whoa why'd he
fire you so I told him I was going to a
rave for uh New Year's Eve and I was
going to be in Arizona for a few days
how old were you told him uh 21 21 okay
and then I missed a day at work which I
told him I was going to miss and he was
like you never told me if you're not
going to take this seriously you're
fired and then so I was like okay I'm
fired cool I didn't respond to him
um and then the next day he's like where
are you I'm like you just fired me
yesterday like do you have amnesia
what's going on oh he didn't even
remember
I just I don't know if you didn't
remember or thought that he could shame
me like I was like I thought you fired
me I just I don't even oh like he was
just talking [__] thinking that you
wouldn't really it was a bluff call yeah
and I
say fired at this point I don't care
about money that much so the first 20
years of your life it was amicable with
your pups no oh no I never liked him for
real yeah my friend
kicking him because I told him I didn't
want to be picked up and he was trying
to pick me up so I kicked him and ran so
yeah I'm starting early yeah yeah I I
I have of my dad is when I turned 21 and
he took me gambling but I think that's
only a good memory because he gave me
money uh so the associations yeah that's
not Christian like he told you gambling
yeah to teach her that gambling's wrong
where I draw the line so her pops past
you probably wouldn't cry huh
no it's like it would probably be a lot
of different emotions
it'd be like probably a lot of
unresolved feelings coming up the stuff
that like I'm still working on
processing but even on Christmas he like
sent me a car that was like
um
oh [__] like you're perfect the way you
are or something and I'm like ah Bruno
Mars said that yeah
it's like I know you're supposed to be
like I know you're doing exactly what
you're supposed to be doing and I'm like
really after all the years of trauma and
it's crazy because I actually try to
have a conversation with him I think it
was before I even started sex work and I
was like do you know what it does to me
when like you call me a [__] and he's
like you don't think you deserve to be
called [__] that's exactly his response
I was like okay Daddy chill yeah I feel
like when he writes these gestures in a
card it's just like empty gestures I
thought like I just think that like
because he used to try to control me
with money like if you do this I won't
pay for things he doesn't pay for
anything anymore so what he can't like I
just think it's a lot of manipulation
tactics and he he hasn't done any
software and some new [__] yeah he's
trying some that's my opinion trying to
build a relationship now yeah what's
what's your body count for guys you said
I love you too oh that's a good question
oh emotional body count that's a strong
one one I think
wow but you've taken ecstasy in one
night on ecstasy I've told like 7 000
people I loved her
I told him I love them I mean boys and
girls you're telling everybody I swear
to God any guy that was standing next to
me they were like family I love them and
we were like this [__] on Ecstasy but
like I
you're like a brother
you know like every single one I didn't
feel like that a lot with Ecstasy but I
feel that a lot more with mushrooms
okay so how a lot of people describe
their ecstasy experience as how I feel
on mushrooms have you done Ayahuasca I
have not oh we have a guy over here that
works with a shaman wow she's a great
guy
okay so you mentioned that um because
you were uh in a Christian upbringing
yes you felt guilty about watching
regular porn so you would often watch
hentai or Japanese anime yes I did with
the
thing that's all I was gonna
send them what were the things that you
were watching how did you even find it
what were the things that you were
gravitating towards the squid stuff okay
like octopus now
I do have octopus actually no but um
identical point so my mom and dad told
me what sex was like very young I don't
remember why interesting uh oh I think I
think it was just to avoid like any
potential like sexual abuse so it's like
I knew what would be happening to me
like that was like my mom's angle and
telling me really young and then I would
I didn't watch like a lot of Disney
Channel or did like Nickelodeon I watch
Animal Planet and I remember seeing like
they're like these two animals and like
they're Australian accent like are
mating and I was like what oh that's
cool I was like so then I looked up I
didn't know like what porn the name of
it was and I looked up live sex and
that's how I I Googled that
um yeah so then lifesex.com came up and
then I would start and I would be and
then I didn't know what was a sin at
first and then I remember they started
talking about it like
I don't know a year like I was watching
porn pretty regularly didn't know what
to do I didn't know how to masturbate
but I was actually like hot is that yeah
I kept watching it yeah that's crazy
that the safe search was off on your
computer as a kid yeah and then she just
at home with her headphones you could
just watch any like this disturbing
thing that's insane yeah in her dad's
history already all the links are purple
no I knew how to I knew how to clear
search history but um my problem was I
used to click on all of the all of the
pop-ups and then I just the computer
completely crashed yeah hey we've been
there yeah and I didn't get blamed for
it no no because they since the computer
completely crashed I couldn't even they
it couldn't even turn on at that point
they couldn't even see that it was
pouring and I was just like I was that's
the way to do it this is the way to do
it yeah yeah so no one was also my
brother like he did not get in trouble
at that point at that point it was
mainly me he got trouble a lot like
growing up and then I think he just got
the [__] smacked out [__] smacked out of
him where he's like he's like doesn't do
anything wrong I grew up like that and
then all of a sudden I'm like oh it's a
little more fun to get in trouble
um
it's true yeah
Christian childhood yep yeah [__] that
cult
I say that a lot I'm gonna get a lot of
hate for that [__] that Christian so uh
in terms of your only fans which
obviously has uh based off the numbers
you're saying it's very successful yeah
what yeah congratulations what do you
feel like is your like your Niche like
the what makes you stand out or what's
what are you super skilled at uh that I
wow but here's the thing talented no no
men in real life hate it they're like
[__] I gotta clean up this mess like
they shame me for it on only fans all of
a sudden for the first time ever men are
like yes yes and it's like it's I'm not
paying it's like it's squirt it depends
on the kind of guy though yeah yeah
that's true yeah because it's rare to
like just naturally squirt or like yeah
I naturally the first time I squirted I
asked the guy is was that you he's like
no that was you baby girl then he
ghosted me but um it's supposed to be an
ego trip here sounds so cool I've only
had one squirter
that was shocking because I thought she
peed the bed
wait so you have to do the asparagus
thing though I know I need to try I need
I'll report back I just need to buy some
asparagus and eat it and then report
back so so we always we always ask these
questions too when people uh have only
fans come on here like we know that
there's obviously the subscription-based
model but there's also like the strictly
like the DM like yeah my account's
completely free I have over 265 000
subscribers I'm one of the most followed
people and only fans let's go yeah
that's amazing so can you tell us some
of the most wild and zany stories of
people that stayed in your DMs or
requested certain things or for how much
I love the small little shrimp dick
things that they're like humiliate me
cat does the same thing
do they send you a dick pic and say talk
[__] to it yeah they're like they like
put like a clamp on their little shrimpy
and they're like please humiliate me and
I'm like oh I've been waiting to get my
anger out I've been waiting for this
it's a clap like they they put a clamp
on it or something oh yeah why do they
put a clamp on oh and there was one oh
my God this guy this this was like it
looked painful but he put a cigarette in
his pee hole like a lit one well it
wasn't lit but it was a cigarette in his
pee hole and like so they they're
mutilating their dick yeah and it's like
they just they want they want you to
humiliate them they want you to tell
them you're worth they're worthless like
I just but also I I love getting dick
pics it's like one of my favorite things
about only fans and I specifically like
the ones like they'll draw like little
dick art or like it'll just be like yeah
like ever literally when people draw
descar and I'm like oh my God I am so
excited by this because it's like
they're funny and they have a cool
looking dick like it's looking like a
shades on it yeah a scar on it no
actually there was one guy who was like
I don't know how to draw but he put a
bow tie on his dick and I was like I
love that [__] it's just so funny it's a
gentleman yeah you have a life-size
drawing of Joe's dick in this room
somewhere
size
it was you have to scale it perfectly
okay see like each deck is
Dick is like and even if I'm not like
sexually
actually yeah I mean there are some that
are a little frightening but I would say
they're they're not the majority what
would you say is like the regularity of
you getting like shrimp dick humiliate
me type of uh messages and then what are
you charging for that [__] how much do I
charge for that I think if it's just uh
like I have to because I have all that
[__] written down because like off the
top of my head but um it's different
stuff on the menu yeah there's like
they're gonna stop on a menu but I'm
pretty sure it's ten dollars if they
want like a just like typed out one and
then if they want a video of me actually
giving them a dick rating it's like 20
or 30 or just something like that I'd
have to again look but then if they want
me to be like saying their name and like
doing all do a rap freestyle yeah yeah
like it would just be a lot more like
the more thought that's behind it the
more it is
geez you have your menu on you
can you do a DubStep track about my dick
and rap about it please hey now you
could just use Chad gbt for sure like oh
my God you don't even have to think you
don't have to ride it out
wow that's so big dang that's the moment
when like only famous people or anybody
who like get those requests can AI their
own voice to just respond to these
things you could play AI an entire whole
person beginning to end oh yeah yeah
because they're doing deep fake even the
content yeah all of it remember that one
influence I
20 dollars
more to have me actually like be naked
25 recent private nudes for my camera
roll which I do actually take like nudes
almost every day and then
um fifty dollars girl girl dildo action
75 squirting a hundred uh all whole
stuffed and [__] uh with a joggy with
strap on and then I have a lot more
content too like the sex tape for
example I don't like to send it
um I only like to send it to people who
are requesting it so I can charge more
because it's like that is special like I
only have that video or like it's a
secret menu yeah it's like a secret menu
yeah it's the Tomahawk Steak
wrapped in gold full foil dude
um but and also like the all whole stuff
it's like a lot more because my [__]
just rejects butt plugs and now so it's
like that's also special content oh it
doesn't do it
oh it just shoots it back shoots it back
out like and it's painful oh so you
gotta take that off the menu girl well
no I I have a lot of those videos oh
logged out I have a lot of videos with
all the whole stuff but that's just why
it's more expensive
this is like your highly requested what
is your staple like you know how you
know in and out has like the double
double that everyone gets or whatever
like what's what's your what's your best
what's your name what's your best seller
yeah what's the thing that they always
get is it like to talk [__] to my dick
uh I get a lot of a lot of things like
oh I mean it like I I have 265 000
subscribers like I get a lot of
different kinds we're talking about when
you look at your analytics and you're
like this makes the most money
um I mean the boy girl makes the most
money because it's so rare but I don't
have a lot of that like the sex tape so
yeah like the sex tape that I have makes
the most money Joys make a lot of money
like jerk off instructions girl girl
makes a lot of money and then he likes
DIYs uh dick rates make a lot of money
and I mean the sporting does make a lot
of money too but it's like to actually
squirt it's like you know like usually
girls put on a performance when they're
masturbating it's like if I'm squirting
I'm not putting on a performance I'm
actually trying to come so I can squirt
you know but like those also like
they're they're very very requested so
yeah I mean I guess those are all my top
things what's what's the most expensive
request that you declined and you're
like I'm not doing that oh my god I've
had quite a few have you had a Saudi
Arabian Royal tell you to poop
is there a price or is that a no no
matter what well here's the problem is
it's against only fans terms of service
privately
yeah you can't do that oh wow a lot of
pee content I used to love because I pee
a lot like why wouldn't I sell my pea
content and then um yeah they take that
down so it's like I can't do poop I mean
there was someone asking me to like
like [__] myself on like a basketball
outside with a dildo and it was just
like very bespoke I'm not do they want
you to wear a basketball jersey too it
was just like a lot of crazy stuff like
like it was so specific down to like the
second of what they wanted and I'm like
there's no way I'm gonna like this is
like memorizing a script I'm not gonna
do that even if it was a thousand
dollars I didn't care oh yeah oh geez
yeah we are unfortunately at the end of
the video and you obviously are so open
and willing to share you don't have to
answer this question in the answer but
just in the context what is something
that if we asked you about this thing
you would be embarrassed to share about
it
I used to be a Republican
you'd be embarrassed about that yeah
so so you you're anti-republican views
right now yeah well that's not so
embarrassing to say you use that's like
everybody no no I I had to delete oh you
were hardcore whole Facebook
when did when did it stop after Arizona
because I mean yeah Arizona made it a
lot worse Arizona everyone was like
pro-trump oh you voted for Hillary what
a [__] [__] like it was crazy so
then all of a sudden I started um
actually doing research and not just uh
watching Fox News and I'm like oh
actually a lot of Republicans are
[__] stupid
um
so yeah acid yeah
[Music]